hello everybody and welcome to the
Macmillan Center for the second in this
series of Stimpson lecture series on
Shapiro the director here and it's it's
one of my privileges to select the
Simpson lecturer Susan Dunn is the
Massachusetts professor of humanities at
Williams College and she's author of a
dozen books many of you will know her
from her frequent reviews in the New
York Times Book Review and the New York
Review of Books but her books the to my
two favorites which I think really
exemplify her characteristic skill of
mixing but micro stories with big
questions who tell us she tells micro
story in a way that illuminates a very
big question the first don't I read
Jefferson's second revolution the
election crisis of 1800 which is about
the fact I was alerted to it by
political scientist we we trafficking
the idea that those of us who study
democracy that you can't call a country
a democracy until they've been to
turnovers of power where government that
has lost an election voluntarily gives
up power and it turns out that the the
best prediction of alternation is
alternation and so it's very important
how it gets going once there's been one
or two it tends to continue indefinitely
and even though it was to some extent
called into question when mr. Trump said
he might not accept the results of the
election it is in fact well-established
in her foreign 1800 deals with the first
iteration of ultra of alternation and
it's a riveting account of those weeks
and months in 1800 and then the other
book that again a great favorite and his
certain topical relevance is her book on
1940 FDR wealthy
bird hits let the election amid this
storm it's I think characteristic again
a throwback from the current election I
make you can correct me if I'm wrong but
I think Wendell Willkie is the only
other businessman who's ever being a
major party candidate for presidency
it's all right I think so dangerous to
make decisions of this kind you find it
maybe that's true so also a very very
interesting book she's here today to
give three lectures on FDR's third
hundred days preparing for war and
global leadership 1940 November 1942
March 1941 today is the second of those
three lectures entitled a declaration of
independence lend-lease I hope you'll
join us again tomorrow for the final
lecture on speed and speed now
mobilizing industry and labor for war
the funding for these lectures comes
from an anonymous donor in honor of
Henry L Stimson Yale College of 1889 an
attorney and statement whose government
service culminated with his tenure as
Secretary of War during World War two
since 1998 the Macmillan Center and Yale
University Press have collaborated on
bringing distinguished diplomats and
foreign policy experts as well as
scholars to the center to lecture on and
and their books are published by Yale
University Press I won't give you the
entire list of previous Stimson lecture
books but Samuel Huntington's putting
order and change in political order in
changing society was one and arms and
arms and influenced by Thomas Schelling
was another not to mention the imprint
of Congress by David may you get with us
this afternoon and so I'm pleased to
introduce Professor Susan
I must say I'm a great admirer of
Professor Shapiro's work - and it's also
an honor to speak in the Henry Stimson
lecture series because Stimson is one of
my heroes and in fact also is Henry Luce
and we have-we happen to be speaking in
the Henry Luce building at Yale okay a
declaration of interdependence
lend-lease in 1789 Alexander Hamilton
said we think in English for me that
short sentence encapsulate s' the
profound intellectual political and
cultural ties that bind the United
States and Great Britain in 1940 when
wave after wave of Nazi bombers were
dropping their lethal cargo over English
cities and ports and reducing to
smoldering ruins port facilities war
factories schools hospitals churches the
famous Greenwich Observatory theaters
shops and entire working-class
neighborhoods Secretary of the Navy
Frank nock said and I quote from a
cultural standpoint it would be a
calamity for us if British life were
uprooted the question I'd like to
discuss with you today is whether the
former British colonies in the new world
would come to the rescue of their mother
country the country that bequeathed to
us the anglo-saxon enlightenment
principles of freedom under law
self-government and the right of
individuals to due process and the
answer to that question is yes during
the period that I call Franklin
Roosevelt's third hundred days between
November 1940 and March 41 the president
decided that the United States did
indeed have to come to the rescue of
Great Britain he offered a stunning
proposal known
lend-lease and act the Prime Minister
Winston Churchill called the most
unsorted act in all of recorded history
and it all began in the office of
Treasury Secretary Henry Morgenthau and
on board a Navy ship the USS Tuscaloosa
as it sailed in sunny Caribbean waters
in early December 1940 a few weeks after
he won an unprecedented third term in
the White House President Roosevelt
looking tired and drawn decided to
exchange gray and cold Washington for a
warm water cruise sailing had always
offered him a relaxed setting for
fishing card games with his pals
martinis and movies shown on the deck in
the evenings before he left Washington
for Miami where he boarded the
Tuscaloosa one reporter asked him why he
wouldn't say where he was going well he
replied I won't deceive you we're going
to Christmas Island to buy Christmas
cards and then we're going on to Easter
Island to buy Easter eggs the president
was leaving behind a capital city that
was discouraged by his inaction with the
election over now many people in
Washington and London expected him to
act decisively on aid to Britain and
they wondered if the Roosevelt
administration was empty of the ideas
and energy needed to address the global
crisis the answer wasn't long and coming
on December 3rd the day Roosevelt
boarded the Tuscaloosa in Miami the key
military and civilian players and his
administration were meeting in secretary
Morgenthau's office the subject was
Britain's latest order for 2 billion
dollars worth of munitions and the
daunting fact that Britain was a billion
dollars short and the question was how
could and how would the United States
help Britain since the election the
administration had been floundering for
an answer and coming to no decision
but at that December 3rd meeting there
was a clear consensus that the so-called
cash-and-carry requirement on British
orders a requirement imposed by the
Neutrality Act was no longer viable
an alternative had to be found are we
going to pay for the war from now on
Frank Knox asked yes got to no choice
about it he said answering his own
question they all realized that the
amounts of money involved were enormous
and that giving away military property
to the British on so massive a scale
could spark all kinds of legal political
and even constitutional issues and so
the group concurred that it was
essential to get congressional
authorization for new lines of credit to
Great Britain it would be a hard sell
not only to the isolationists in
Congress but also to those who believe
that the British were only pleading
poverty and that they really had vast
wealth hidden away and so a masterpiece
of persuasion would be needed to
convince Congress and the public to
accept a radical new program of all aid
to Britain short of war no such weighty
meetings took place on board the
tuscaloosa that is not until November
December 9th when a navy plane delivered
a special letter for Roosevelt from
Winston Churchill the Prime Minister
later remarked that it was one of the
most important letters he ever wrote
with that letter the urgency of
Britain's desperate plight burst onto
the deck of the Tuscaloosa and
catapulted Roosevelt from calm sunny
seas back into a dark war-torn world
Churchill began his letter with the
solemnity of which he was a master he
wrote the future of our two democracies
and the kind of civilization for which
they stand are bound up with the
survival and independence of the British
Commonwealth of
patience he made it plain that the
future of the whole world now depended
on the help that the United States gave
to Britain Churchill recognized that his
nation had to hold the Atlantic front
and fend off the Nazi onslaught until
the United States was sufficiently
prepared militarily to intervene but
because of that foundational identity of
interest between the two nations
Churchill whose mother was American
asked Roosevelt for what he called
supreme and decisive help in what is our
common cause that supreme help did not
include American soldiers although the
Prime Minister believed that the
involvement of the American army and
navy was inevitable and essential to
ultimate victory he couldn't yet say
that to his American cousins after 4,000
painful and troubling words Churchill
finally got to the core of his message
and it was money he informed Roosevelt
that the moment approaches when we shall
no longer be able to pay cash for
shipping and other supplies Churchill's
letter reflected the depths of British
dependence on the United States to bring
what he called the agony of civilization
to a positive conclusion the proud
leader of the world's greatest empire
was begging the American president for
help
as he famously said give us the tools
and we will finish the job for several
days while he was sailing in the pure
Caribbean light the president considered
and waved Churchill's letter and then
with an alacrity that had gone missing
of late he decided upon one of the most
consequential policies of the entire war
a commitment to arm the British entirely
at American expense it would be the most
open and resolute statement yet of where
the United States
stood a statement that would bind the
nation to the fate of Great Britain if
the president's plan was approved by
Congress the Roosevelt administration
after months of indecision would finally
be assuming leadership of the democratic
forces in the war of two worlds over the
next three months the president would
build on that new idea and create the
groundwork for an unprecedented
expansion of American power and enduring
global leadership enduring until last
Tuesday on December 17th the day after
his return to Washington Roosevelt met
with his Treasury secretary over lunch
and told him about his proposal we'll
say to England we'll give you the guns
and ships you need provided that when
the war is over you'll return to them
you'll return them to us in kind well
what do you think yes that's the best
idea yet Morgenthau said and it had a
good chance of passage in Congress if
Congress could be convinced that the
u.s. was driving a hard bargain the two
men agreed that they had come up with a
smart idea for a giveaway program that
didn't look like one that same afternoon
December 17th FDR held one of his most
important press conferences as usual he
began by casually saying that well he
really didn't have any particular news
but then he can see that well there was
one small item he could mention he told
the reporters that from a selfish point
of view in order to assure American
defense it was extremely important that
we do everything to help the British
Empire to defend itself and that meant
supplying Britain with war the war
material it's so urgently needed one
reporter asked about payment
now what I'm trying to do
FDR memorably said its eliminate the
dollar sign the silly foolish old dollar
sign here's an illustration suppose my
neighbor's home catches fire and I have
a long garden hose if he takes my garden
hose and connects it to his hydrant I
can help him put out his fire now I
don't say to him before that operation
neighbor my garden hose cost me 15 bucks
you have to pay me 15 bucks for it
I don't want $15 I want my garden hose
back after the fire is over but what if
it gets smashed up he'll replace it well
if I get a nice garden hose back I'm in
pretty good shape
another reporter asked the president if
he thought his new plan takes us any
further into the war than we are
the president was ready with a short
reply nope not at all Roosevelt had
attractively framed his surprising new
policy in moral and practical terms
he was purporting to follow the golden
rule by generously offering neighborly
assistance to England the mother country
and as a pragmatic politician he also
conceived his help as a loan to be
repaid somehow in kind after the war but
he didn't divulge that he was also
acting realistically an American
self-interest in a sense maneuvering and
exploiting Britain to ensure the
security of the United States he would
provide war materiel to British soldiers
so that they like a mercenary army or an
expeditionary force could do the
fighting for him this was a quid pro quo
that would probably have been rejected
by any country not as desperate for
survival as Britain was but the United
States was most definitely in a position
to dictate terms and Churchill's letter
had acknowledged
much two weeks later on December 29th a
Sunday evening
Roosevelt was wheeled into the
diplomatic reception room in the White
House to deliver his 16th fireside chat
a few other people were in the room some
cabinet members the president's mother
and the Hollywood actor Clark Gable and
his wife the actress Carole Lombard
across the country more than 500 radio
stations were tuned to his microphones
and his talk was beamed around the globe
by shortwave estimates were that 100
million people around the world were
listening from New York to California
the country came to a standstill
Roosevelt began by saying that the Nazi
masters of Germany had made it clear
that they intended to enslave the whole
of Europe and then dominate the rest of
the world he called it the worst form of
tyranny one in which there was no
Liberty no religion no hope and because
Britain was the spearhead of resistance
to Nazi world conquest he said that the
United States would pledge to send to
Britain every ounce and every tonne of
munitions and supplies that we can
possibly spare but if the British were
going to insulate the United States from
active participation in war the
president went on american defense
industries needed to operate around the
clock building up to his finale
he said that guns planes and ships have
to be built in the factories and
Arsenal's of america the purpose of the
nation is to build now with all possible
speed every machine and Arsenal and
factory and then he uttered the words
that would go down in history we must be
the great arsenal of democracy while
Roosevelt was delivering this talk
German bombers descended on London
delivering the worst incendiary attack
since the beginning of the Blitz that
past September those planes dropped
10,000 bombs and reduced East London to
a flaming skeleton the New York Times
London correspondent wrote that people
who were in the East End said it was
like being trapped in a forest fire when
they tried to get out of that blazing
doomed part of London they found
themselves hemmed in by new fires and by
buildings that were toppling over in
front of them the following morning
Churchill trudged through the
smouldering muddy streets surveying the
terrible devastation one woman shouted
out to him what about peace the Prime
Minister stared hard at her and he
snarled peace when we will have beaten
them back in Washington the White House
was flooded with telegrams and letters
from across the country by hundred to
one Americans expressed enthusiasm for
the president's arsenal address The
Washington Post
conducted man-in-the-street interviews
in a drugstore on 14th Street the
counter man told the reporter we've got
to get behind the president and I mean
everybody boy as he writes at a
cabdriver a few days after the
president's fireside chat the Gallup
poll found that 68% of Americans were
convinced that the fate of America was
tied to that of Britain and it wasn't
for sentimental reasons or blood ties or
a common language Gallup wrote it was
more for selfish reasons that they
believed that their own safety depended
on a British victory but the President
had not vanquished the hardcore
isolationist bloc in Congress led by
Montana's Democratic senator Burton
wheeler wheeler took the position as he
said that the preservation of American
democracy does not do
and upon any foreign nation wheeler
advocated for what he called a just
reasonable and generous peace with
Germany for Roosevelt and his cabinet it
looked like a tough year ahead on New
Year's Eve two days after the
president's fireside chat Secretary of
War Henry Stimson noted in his diary
that he and his wife went to bed early
he wrote there seemed to be no jus no
occasion for jubilation over the coming
in of the new year because 1941 is
fraught with all kinds of ominous
forebodings we might feel this way on
December 31st 2016 - a week later FDR
delivered his State of the Union address
the crucial issues were still aid to
Britain and speeding up war production
but Roosevelt decided to give the speech
a new turn and push out its horizon to a
vision of the post-war world at the end
of his talk he described that world as
one that would be founded on four
essential universal human freedoms he
said the first is freedom of speech and
expression everywhere in the world the
second was the freedom of every person
to worship God in his own way
everywhere in the world the third was
freedom from want by which he meant
economic agreements among nations for
example concerning trade and monetary
policy that would help secure for their
inhabitants a healthy peacetime life
everywhere in the world the fourth was
freedom from fear which meant a
worldwide reduction of armaments so that
no nation would be in a position to
commit an act of physical aggression
against any neighbor anywhere in the
world the first two freedoms were well
known there are First Amendment rights
freedom of speech press conscience and
belief those rights expressed the
freedom of the individual against
government interference freedom from
want reflected the New Deal philosophy
of rights not against government but
instead rights through government
freedom from want meant rights not just
to food and shelter but also to
healthcare education a job and rights to
collective bargaining minimum wages and
fair labor standards and finally freedom
from want meant security and old age
freedom from fear recalled Woodrow
Wilson's League of Nations
FDR looked forward to an effective
international organization that would
mediate disputes before war broke out
and that would oversee disarmament FDR's
hope for arms reduction might remind us
of President Obama's talk last spring
and Hiroshima in which he said we must
have the courage to escape the logic of
fear and pursue a world without nuclear
stockpiles freedom from want and freedom
from fear were connected in Roosevelt's
mind he believed that many of the roots
of Nazi fascism and German hyper
nationalism could be traced to the
economic deprivation and dislocation
that resulted from the Great Depression
FDR's point was that if people could be
assured a freedom from want in the
post-war world they'd be far less likely
to succumb to demagogues and less driven
to aggression and violence the Four
Freedoms in a sense gave a moral meaning
and purpose to the war they offered the
basis for a post-war world founded on
individual freedom and prosperity
tolerance in every dimension and
international peace and security if you
have a visual memory of Norman Rock
quells famous illustrations of the four
freedoms they portrayed those freedoms
in an exclusively American context but
FDR had stressed that all human beings
everywhere in the world were entitled to
those four essential human freedoms your
Yale graduate Henry Luce explicitly
embraced FDR's international vision in
his famous February 1941 article the
American Century for loose the future
was not about American power the
American Century was rather about the
generous and moral commitment of the
United States to the security and
well-being of the rest of the planet On
January 20th 1941 the day of FDR's
inauguration he gave the third speech in
a momentous sequence his third inaugural
address it was a philosophical almost
spiritual talk that centered on the
argument that democracy was not dying
and that in fact it couldn't die because
it was Roosevelt said the most humane
the most advanced and in the end the
most unconquered bull of all forms of
human society using one of the
unpretentious homi analogies that he
liked to include in his talks he
explained that a nation was like a
person it had a physical intellectual
and spiritual life its body must be
clothed fed and housed its mind must be
kept informed and alert but a nation
like a person has something deeper
something more permanent than the sum of
all its parts the president called it a
spirit a living faith a quasi divine
purpose in life an ongoing quest for
freedom justice equality and happiness
to keep that Democratic aspirational
I've in a time of brutal war
fair he said that all citizens would be
called upon to make countless sacrifices
but the sacrifice but the survival of
that precious spirit would furnish the
highest justification for every
sacrifice we make after the drama of
Roosevelt's arsenal of democracy
fireside chat and his for freedom State
of the Union speech the inaugural
address fell fell a little flat what
caught much more notice was the military
spectacle following that address
parading down Pennsylvania Avenue were
units of cavalry infantry Navy Coast
Guard Marines West Point cadets and
Annapolis ship Midshipmen then came
Scout cars motorcycles and tanks
airplanes soared overhead in formation
it was a staggeringly militaristic
extravaganza and that was exactly the
message that FDR wanted to send the
nation was willing to fight for the
democratic way of life On January 10th
representative John McCormack of
Massachusetts the House Majority Leader
and Senate Majority Leader alben Barkley
of Kentucky simultaneously introduced
the lend-lease bill it was anak you
asleep titled
to promote the defense of the United
States and for other purposes
McCormick gave the legislation the
revolutionary and patriotic label House
Resolution 1776 1776 the tumultuous year
when the thirteen colonies declared
independence from Great Britain because
the dastardly King had violated their
rights as Englishmen and now Americans
were declaring not independence but
interdependence with Great Britain our
mother country for his part Roosevelt
felt
sure that he had the votes in Congress
to pass the legislation and so he
decided not to campaign for it openly
and to hold back on the arm-twisting but
behind the scenes he played the defining
role in overseeing the drafting of the
bill and dictating the way the
administration would sell it on January
15th Secretary of State Cordell Hull and
Treasury secretary Morgan thow testified
before the House Foreign Relations
Committee hull painted a grim picture of
the ruthless and implacable Nazi enemy
and maintained that lend-lease was
essential to the goal of American
defense and self-preservation Morgenthau
meanwhile gave a lengthy detailed report
demonstrating that the British simply
didn't have the dollars to pay for the
arms they needed the next day it was
Henry Stimson Stern and he was blunt if
the British Navy was destroyed he said
the US would be in real and great danger
of invasion so by coming to the aid of
Great Britain the US was in a sense
buying not lending Stimson told
committee members that we are buying our
own security while we prepare the US was
also buying time time to gear up its
industrial defense production what he
did not say was that we were buying
blood to the blood of British soldiers
who would die in battle while the u.s.
remained on the sidelines and built up
its defenses and he also didn't say what
he truly believed that American soldiers
would eventually have to fight and die
to get the job done as he wrote in his
diary
we cannot permanently be in a position
of toolmakers for other nations that
fight but he also realized that with
lend-lease the president had gone as far
as he could go politically at least for
the time being
after Stimson it was Frank Knox's
the Secretary of the Navy pointed out
that the British fleet in the Atlantic
had historically shielded the United
States from attack and in 1941 American
security on the Atlantic front would
depend more than ever on Britain's
ability to control the seas the
administration had made its case time
now to hear from the isolationist
opponents of lend-lease first up was
FDR's former ambassador to Great Britain
Joseph P Kennedy in England Kennedy had
developed a friendly relationship with
Prime Minister Chamberlain the arch
appeaser who had paved Hitler's way to
world war kennedy had also gravitated
toward the pro-nazi appeasers in
britain's high society known as the
clifden set the fall of 1940 he returned
to the US and although he was an
unrepentant isolationist he gave FDR a
boost in Massachusetts by supporting his
re-election but a few days after
Roosevelt's win Kennedy chatted with a
reporter from the Boston Globe
and he blurted out his bizarre opinion
that democracy was finished in England
and that it was probably finished in the
United States too FDR was furious when
he read the interview it was the tipping
point after a long train of vexations he
said to Eleanor I never want to see that
son of a [ __ ] again as long as I live
Kennedy handed in his resignation and
for the rest of his life he was toast he
testified in the House a few weeks after
his resignation he didn't deny that the
situation in Britain was very critical
or that the Luftwaffe is nightly raids
on English cities and ports had
intensified and he did support some aid
to Britain but he was against the
lend-lease bill because he said it gave
the
president a blank check and he piously
hoped for something much more modest
next came Charles Lindbergh the
isolationists famous spokesman and the
man I love to hate in fact it's one of
my favorite hobbies for hours
Lindbergh's admirers had waited in line
hoping for seats in the visitors gallery
and the chance to see their hero in
action no surprise that Lindbergh very
uhland Lee opposed lend-lease a second
after he took his seat he began the
litany it would be a grave mistake for
the United States to extend any aid to
Great Britain
Britain's war with Nazi Germany was
simply not an American affair the US
could remain safely isolated from the
rest of the world on a little side note
on December 7th 1941 Lindbergh was
staggered by the news of the attack on
Pearl Harbor and he wrote in his diary
how did the Japs get close enough to
attack us ever since Lindbergh first
visit to Germany in 1936
he'd been intoxicated with the Nazis
advances in aviation technology and so
he convinced himself that no matter how
much help Britain might receive from the
u.s. it couldn't possibly win the war
that was merely his opening statement
then he responded to questions when one
skeptical congressman asked him which
side he wanted to win he offered this
piece of moral discernment I prefer to
see neither side win between Britain and
Nazi Germany there is not as much
difference in philosophy as we have been
led to believe and how did he propose to
resolve the Nazi onslaught on Britain
well since he attributed equal blame to
both sides he called for a negotiated
peace anyway the real danger to the u.s.
lay here at home he told committee
members that Roosevelt posed a greater
threat to the United States than did
Hitler a panoply of other
interventionists followed Lindbergh all
making more or less the same arguments
equally in vain the lend-lease bill was
voted out of committee and after a week
a floor debate in the House on February
8 the representatives quickly passed the
bill by a vote of 260 to 165 a day after
Churchill heard the news in London he
spoke on the radio to express his
gratitude and to reassure Americans that
the British did not need American
soldiers that same week the famous
American war correspondent Ernie Pyle
sent back to the u.s. from London a
dispatch describing his visit to the air
raid shelter at the Liverpool Street
tube I wasn't emotionally ready to see
people lying around by the thousands on
cold concrete he wrote many were old
richard wretched and worn old people
people who had never known any of the
good things in life there were children
to some asleep and some playing there
were smart alecks
and there were quiet ones there were
hard working people of middle age who
had to rise at 5:00 and go to work
think of yourself now traveling at dusk
every night to a subway station sitting
there all night and fitful sleep think
of that is your destiny every night
every night from now on the Senate
Foreign Relations Committee began its
hearings on lend-lease in late January
the cast of characters was familiar hull
Morgenthau Stimson knox Lindbergh and
his motley crew of isolationists one new
witness was a Yale University scene
named Kingman Brewster the chairman of
Yale's America first chapter
isolationists on the committee had
chosen him to put a young respectable
face on their movement in his testimony
Brewster praised the courage and
straightforwardness of Colonel Lindbergh
and said that President Roosevelt
intentionally or unintentionally was
pushing for policies that in fact added
up to war he made the argument that the
United States was strong enough to fight
off any enemy on our own shores and that
therefore if a transatlantic war was to
be waged it made sense to force the
enemy to cross the water and try to land
here on another side note right after
the passage of lend-lease Brewster
acknowledged that the u.s. had now
clearly rejected isolationism and he
resigned from the America first
committee after Pearl Harbor he
volunteered for the Navy and served
until 1946 by then he was an
internationalist and was soon helping to
implement the Marshall Plan in Europe he
came back to New Haven in 1960 but the
real star of the Senate hearings was
Wendell Willkie Roosevelt's Republican
opponent in the 1940 election Wilkie had
never before run for public office and
until 1939 he'd been a Democrat and so
he had been the dark horse at the GOP
convention he was also a solid
interventionist and anti-fascist and he
was way ahead of Roosevelt on civil
rights in early January 1941 two months
after losing the election Wilkie issued
a strong public statement supporting
lend-lease he wrote it is the history of
democracy that under such dire
circumstances extraordinary powers must
be granted to the elected executive
democracy cannot hope to defend itself
from aggression
in any other way and he pleaded with
Republicans to support lend-lease and
put patriotism above partisanship
later that month when FDR heard that
Wilkie was planning a trip to England he
reached out and asked him to serve
informally as his emissary to Churchill
but while Wilkie was in England he
received an urgent cable from Cordell
Hull asking him to hurry back to
Washington and testify in favor of
lend-lease and of course he immediately
agreed on February 11th the huge Senate
caucus chamber was packed with more than
a thousand people all eager to witness
the dramatic spectacle of a defeated
presidential candidate coming to the
assistance of his victorious opponent
Wilkie looked tired from his journey and
he appeared but he appeared relaxed and
there was no fatigue in his voice when
he told committee members that the
people of Britain are united almost
beyond belief there are free people
millions of them will die before they
give up that Island after acknowledging
that the lend-lease bill gave the
president new powers he said with his
usual charm now I'm as much opposed to
any man in America to undue
concentration of power in the chief
executive and may I say that I did my
best to remove that power from the
present executive nevertheless he urged
that the bill be adopted with as he said
a nonpartisan and unanimous vote
isolationists in both parties grilled
Wilkie but he answered their questions
with wit candor and good humor when
asked about his own biting criticism of
FDR during the campaign he breezily said
well that was just campaign oratory and
then he added Roosevelt is my president
now
FDR could not have hoped for a better
advocate
two days after Wilkie's testimony the
Senate Foreign Relations Committee
approved lend-lease by a vote of 15 to 8
when floor debate in the Senate began
the galleries were jam-packed with
unruly visitors who were repeatedly
scolded for their cheers as well as
their catcalls one of the first to speak
was Democrat Claude pepper of Florida
lay it down as a premise he said America
will not let England fall to Hitler when
one isolationist democrat insisted that
there was nothing worse than war war in
Austin at Vermont Republican who was one
of the bills most energetic supporters
stood up in the center aisle and
dramatically declared oh there are much
worse things than war a world enslaved
by Hitler is much worse than war it's
worse than death if ever it becomes
necessary for us to fight we will fight
applause from people in the galleries
drowned out a smattering of boos other
internationalists Republicans as well as
Democrats praised lend-lease
for being the only channel available for
providing the aid to Britain and for
gaining time to a gear up American
defense production even though opponents
of lend-lease had little new to say they
dominated the debate speaking three
times more than the bill supporters they
insisted that the defeat of Britain
would not be fatal to our national
existence and they branded lend-lease a
Trojan horse that would lead to a
Roosevelt dictatorship one Democratic
isolationist from Missouri declared that
England was fighting only for her
commercial supremacy another
isolationist from North Carolina
asserted that Hitler was no more of a
menace to the United States the Napoleon
had been in a
10:08 he held that the British were
merely scheming to exploit American
money and live and their lives in order
to protect their empire and he demanded
that before the u.s. extended any help
to Britain British aristocrats must
strip themselves of their hunting lodges
and their castles their horses their
hounds and their Falcons the strategy of
the isolationist seemed to consist in
talking the bill to death and dragging
out the proceedings until by some
miracle public opinion turned against it
one isolationist senator from South
Dakota said he hoped that Congress would
keep on debating the bill until Europe
settled its own affairs opponents of
lend-lease also forced the Senate to
work through countless amendments some
were significant such as a proposal to
prevent the president from deploying the
military outside of the Western
Hemisphere but many others were simply
irrelevant like an amendment to ban
communists from the federal bureaucracy
several compromise amendments were
finally agreed to by senators who were
anxious to end debate and vote on the
bill when one isolationist made a
last-ditch assault on the president's
honesty he was interrupted by a loud
chorus of vote vote the roll call lasted
just six minutes the tally was 60 in
favor and 31 opposed the Senate's bill
with its compromise amendments was
hurried over to the house for its
approval and the house immediately
passed it by a bipartisan vote of 317 to
71 Speaker Sam Rayburn of Texas and vice
president Henry Wallace signed the act
rushed it over to the White House where
FDR quickly read it and scrolled his
signature on it with lightning swiftness
on that same day March 11th lend-lease
became Lowa Congress had overwhelmingly
approved as a sigh civ an enduring act
of internationalism
an act that set the United States on a
course to global leader
in the House of Commons Churchill
expressed Britain's deep gratitude to
the United States and described
lend-lease as a new Magna Carta this
time it was a charter of the
responsibilities of free democratic
nations to uphold healthy humanist
and moral civilization the following
weekend Roosevelt gave a wonderful
speech at the White House Correspondents
Association dinner first came songs by
entertainers and the usual comic skits
performed by reporters then the
president spoke for more than half an
hour once again his words were carried
not only across the country on the radio
but around the world translated into 14
languages and this is what he said the
big news story of the week is this the
world has been told that we as a united
nation realized the danger that
confronts us and that to meet that
danger our democracy has gone into
action then he portrayed the
isolationist opposition to lend-lease
that had caused him so much frustration
as proof of the vitality and openness of
American democracy he said we've just
now engaged in a great debate in the
halls of Congress in every newspaper and
on every wavelength yes the decisions of
our democracy maybe slowly arrived at
but when that decision is made its
proclaimed not with the voice of any one
man but with the voice of 130 million it
is binding on us all and the world is no
longer left in doubt this decision is
the end of any attempts at appeasement
in our land the end of urging us to get
along with dictators the end of
compromise with tyranny and the forces
of oppression then he turned to the
immense task of putting America in
just real production into full swing the
new watchword he said was speed and
speed now and then he reached out to all
classes of Americans whether you were in
the armed services whether you're a
steel worker a machinist or a housewife
a farmer a banker a storekeeper or a
manufacturer - all of you it will mean
sacrifice on behalf of your country and
on behalf of your freedom the light of
democracy must be kept burning he
concluded his talk with a powerful
crescendo in which he used again and
again the short an ordinary verb yet to
Express America's unstoppable
determination to a Britain and defeat
the Nazis gangster regime
he said the peep the British people need
ships from America they will get ships
they need planes from America they will
get planes from America they need food
from America they will get food they
need tanks and guns and ammunition and
supplies of all kinds from America they
will get tanks and guns and ammunition
and supplies of all kinds that powerful
speech announced the end of an era the
era of American isolationism
and retreat from world affairs that
began in 1919 with the Senate's
rejection of Woodrow Wilson's League of
Nations
Wilson was defeated by his own
intransigent and self-righteous refusal
to compromise with Republican opponents
of the league like Wilson Franklin
Roosevelt was an idealist and an
internationalist but he was also a
master politician an idealist without
illusions
he had a far more realistic pragmatic
and supple understanding of how the
world and Congress actually worked the
President had a mighty fine time at
correspondents dinner that evening
according to Roosevelt's speech writer
Sam Rosenman after wins Rosenman
Roosevelt and a few cronies returned to
the White House for post-mortems over a
glass of beer they talked about the
speech and about how well it had gone
over a brand new Gallup poll show showed
that 72% of the voting public now
supported Roosevelt and his policies not
since February 1934 had his approval
rating been so high lend-lease was
transformational America's engagement
with the world would never be the same
Henry Stimson later pronounced it one of
the most important legislative
achievements of the entire war it helped
rescue Britain from the Nazi onslaught
by supplying the British with arms and
other survival tools but along with
those tools we also exported ideas the
story of a great Democratic Republic
committing all its resources to the
fight for freedom and self-determination
everywhere in the world lend-lease would
eventually be extended across all the
oceans to every continent in conclusion
I'd like to quote from our first
president George Washington's farewell
address of 1796 in that text he
highlighted the tremendous advantages of
our detached and distant geographical
position in the world then he posed a
question why by interweaving our destiny
with that of any part of Europe should
we entangle our peace and prosperity in
the toils of European ambition it is our
true policy to steer clear of permanent
alliances with any portion of the
foreign world but in that same address
Washington also expressed the hope that
one day the United States and his words
as a free and light
and great nation will give to mankind
the magnanimous example of a people
guided by justice and benevolence
well lend-lease certainly fulfilled
Washington's hope that the United States
would present to mankind a magnanimous
example of a people guided by justice
and benevolence though perhaps also
guided by in life and self-interest
lend-lease however was antithetical to
Washington's advice that the nation
remained distant and detached from the
rest of the world and not entangle
itself in the toils of Europe but we
also know that Washington respected the
counsel of Alexander Hamilton and it was
Hamilton who memorably said that we
think in English and so after much
reflection I've come to the conclusion
that if George Washington and the
Broadway star Alexander Hamilton had
been able to return to planet Earth in
1941 they would definitely have been
very pleased and proud to see the
formerly rebellious and bratty children
in the thirteen colonies make a
magnanimous and enlightened declaration
of interdependence with their mother
country thank you
so we we do have a little time for
questions and discussion maybe I could
start off with with one question to you
you made it very clear that a big part
of the politics of getting this through
Congress was keeping silent tones on any
kind of commitment of American troops
and that oh yes even though he knew
would you suspect that that was
inevitably going to be revived by sort
of limiting it as approximate goal and
no American boots on the ground he was
able to fend off a lot of a lot of the
opposition to it but what I'm wondering
which I get you to speculate about a
little bit of course that was all
short-circuited in December of 41
because Japan and then Germany's
declaration of war on the US but for
that do you think committing troops to
Europe would have unraveled the support
and the coalition that he had managed to
put together for many days that's a good
question and no one knows the answer
what would have happened we were
becoming more active in the war in the
fall of 1941 when FDR was somewhat
deceptive an American ship the Greer was
torpedoed by German submarines and at
that point FDR's announced a new policy
which is shoot on sight so at that point
we really work quite involved in
military naval action but where
Roosevelt had been deceptive was that I
think it was a British plane that told
the American the American ship the Greer
that there were German submarines nearby
and that it it what if the attack wasn't
the kind of sudden attack that American
State Department Award
and presented it as but FDR used that
episode of the greer to escalate
inter-american intervention and naval
offensive operations but without Pearl
Harbor I don't know what would have
happened
perhaps Marshall Stimpson and NOx would
have continued to push him toward more
intervention which they had already
started in November 1940 with plan
absolutely absolutely it was in 1944 I
think it was FDR State of the Union in
January 44 that he announced his
economic Bill of Rights and he said now
he expected the war to end shortly and
not too shortly another year but he said
the millions of boys are going to be
coming home to the United States and we
have to give them a good life now and
then he said we have our Bill of Rights
freedom of speech religion conscience
press but that's not enough and then he
said necessitous men are not free men
that in order to be free we have to have
certain economic rights then he gave a
list of his economic Bill of Rights
which is was very idealistic and that we
still have not fulfilled today because
among those rights were right to health
care and to an excellent education a
living wage which we do not have in this
country and many more things did who I
would assume so I he speaks about the
the in the Four Freedoms talk he
specifically defines it as a bit as a
post-war vision of the whole world
everywhere in the world
the press covers it very well very fully
in fact there's an there's a database of
historical newspapers online now called
ProQuest
and I do a lot of my research on that
database of historical newspapers and
it's so interesting to me
historians in the past couldn't possibly
have had access to this much material
that unless and I'm always astonished
that I can put in a few keywords
Roosevelt Wilkie and put in a timespan
of days or months or years and time
doesn't exist in cyberspace in less than
a second I'll have all of the articles
about that subject in chronological
order and then I can click on relevance
and then it'll recast them in less than
a second in terms of relevance so
historians today do have that access to
to newspapers that's simply phenomenal
what we also have you can also limit
that search to editorials that's very
very interesting to see where the
newspaper stood for instance the I
looked at endorsements of FDR's
re-election in November 1942 I think
there was just there were just two
national newspapers that endorsed him
the Atlanta Constitution and the Chicago
Defender which was an African American
weekly every other newspaper was
expressed apprehension about the third
term first third term in American
history as far as lend-lease is
concerned most newspapers supported it
the one the didn't was the
most isolationist in the country the
Chicago Tribune that's the most
isolationist and interestingly I'm on
yesterday I spoke about Len plan dog and
American isolationism and and the
America first committee that was founded
actually here at Yale and it was Chicago
industrialists who were the the funders
of the American America first committee
and the the Midwest was the most
isolationist part of the country and and
that's rather interesting and in fact
I'd like her opinion on whether we saw
that in the red and blue map a week ago
the center of the country is all red and
the coasts are blue and the center of
isolationism there was a geographical
centre and isolationism what was
geographically anchored on the map whose
charisma
of course he had a rival thank you for
mentioning the word charisma yes okay
yes that might be true I'll tell you why
and I never did study Latin no Greek but
I does anyone know Greek I'm under the
impression that the word charisma in
Greek means divine gift you do not want
charisma in a leader Adolf Hitler is the
extreme example of a charismatic leader
he so captivates mesmerizes hypnotizes
his followers with his charisma that
they abdicate all of their rational
critical and moral faculties and you can
see on YouTube the mass rallies of
Germans in Nazi Germany reacting to the
charisma of this leader charisma is
anti-democratic and at best it's
anti-democratic at worst its tyranny
perhaps Donald Trump had some sort of
charisma and that might explain why his
followers mindlessly and immorally
followed him you don't want a leader
with charisma you want a leader who
empowers followers and raises their
aspirations to a higher
morale level and well you could use
maybe it's energy maybe instead of
calling a charisma mic might not be the
charisma might be that he offered a
radically new progressive message that
that Hillary Clinton was not announcing
I won't use the word charisma unless
it's with a demagogue but you could say
energy that that that the that the
Elizabeth Warren and Bernie Sanders had
a new kind of energy and they were they
were fired up by their progressive
platform and perhaps Hillary was looking
more to a centrist position and maybe by
definition there's less energy in the
center
that Lindbergh is a Nazi
yes and I've spent a lot of time reading
is the original Lindbergh yes
sterling and while I was going through
them I would say you know this is a man
who's profoundly anti-semitic a lot of
oh oh really oh yeah go through terrible
but epicene and he was obviously very he
was at the 36 Olympics he was yes in 38
yes yes that's a very good point I think
he was a pro fascist his wife wrote the
book and Marlon Byrd the wave of the
future in which he says that fascism is
the wave of the future democracy is 18th
century outmoded
and we're in a kind of Revolutionary era
and she called fascism scum it when it
was and not fascism no I have to
disagree I don't think she said fascism
was the scum but some of Hitler's
excessive policies were the scum and she
quoted that actually from Lawrence Denis
who that's Harvard Graduate who wrote
several published books on American
fascism but about Lindbergh he did one
to defend America he did want to protect
America and when he came back from
Germany and from Europe in when was it
late 38 or 39 he met with Roosevelt and
he met with other cabinet officials and
actually what he did was discuss with
them the technological advances he had
seen in Germany and he warned them that
they had to keep up and there was
Vannevar Bush he spoke to Vannevar Bush
a former president and professor at MIT
and then the head of an institution in
Washington I forget which one maybe
Carnegie and and he convinced Vannevar
Bush that yes the United States had to
catch up
scientifically on weapons technology and
and they proposed the National Defense
and what was it mdac n D arcy National
Defense research and ultimately that
spawned the Manhattan Project and the
Annan bomb and so in fact Lindbergh
played a positive role in awakening the
United States to the work that it had to
do to catch up
technologically militarily with Germany
so I don't like to say anything positive
about Charles Lindbergh but yes he
but he did that and he did that because
as you suggested he wasn't really a Nazi
he did want to protect the United States
and after Pearl Harbor he asked to to to
fly planes in the air core and Roosevelt
said no he wasn't welcome and so
Lindbergh did fly missions in the
Pacific but for a private aircraft
company but he did take the planes up on
the other hand after the war he was very
very unapologetic and said that the
United States had committed atrocities
absolutely on a par with Germany and we
found out much later about his German
mistress in Germany and his German
children yes
if we were still isolationist I think we
are still we just elected an
isolationist president who wants to
withdraw from NATO and who doesn't want
free trade and what am I wrong what do
you think I'm not an expert on politics
today and I'm not a political scientist
who studies international relations and
I think probably many of you know better
than I do what do you think I'm not sure
the 43:44 perhaps even earlier
what what I fold FDR four is the refugee
policy in the 1930s once we were at war
and Germany was sending people off to
the concentration camps and the gas
chambers I don't think there was
anything we could do until we won the
war
and it was a very complicated war on
several different continents and oceans
but in the 1930s in fact in the
beginning of the 1930s Hitler actually
wanted to get rid of the Jews he wanted
them out we wouldn't take them and the
Assistant Secretary of State in the
United States Breckenridge long was a
terrible anti-semite and he was doing
everything he could to block immigration
and there's the the terrible tragedy of
the ship the same Bluest that came to
this country with I don't know how many
600 Jewish passengers and and the first
one went to Cuba then it went to Miami
and we wouldn't let it dock and the
passengers will return to Europe the
ship had to go back there oh really
Peter gay Wow
absolutely Oh Peter goes at Yale yes
a ton proquest a student of mine
discovered something that I didn't know
and he found an article a newspaper
article from 1936 1936 was the 50th
anniversary of France giving to the
United States the Statue of Liberty
and on that day FDR went to Liberty
Island and he gave a speech speaking
about the Statue of Liberty and the the
America is a great country of immigrants
and then he said we now have all the
material we need we don't need more
immigrants and a student and that's in
that that's in the papers and people
don't I never knew about that 1936
there's also the what what feeds into
that of course is the is the Great
Depression and unemployment they don't
want more refugees when my mother came
to the United States from Nazi Germany
in 1938 she was told at Ellis Island by
someone don't say you want to work in
this country say you want to get married
and and I'm grateful to the United
States for letting in my mother and I
love this country and that's why I study
American history and American democracy
and self-government and that's why I am
so worried about our new election that
happened one week ago
you